investigators are saying that the lion
Air Boeing 737 max jet that crashed in
Indonesia last month should not have
been in the air because of a series of
equipment problems they questioned the
airline's maintenance and safety
procedures and the pylons response in
the air a report issued overnight shows
a horrifying struggle to control the
plane before the crash that killed all
189 passengers and crew in its final
moments the captain reportedly asked to
be cleared to 5,000 feet and reported a
flight control problem now there are
about 250 of these 737 max jets that are
in service around the world three US
carriers Southwest American and United
operate almost 50 of them now Boeing has
orders pending for nearly 5,000 more
Kris Van Cleave is at Reagan National
Airport outside Washington Chris good
morning good morning a seasoned
investigator will tell you it is never
one single thing that results in an
accident like this it is a combination
of factors that lead to tragedy and this
report shows us that investigators are
focusing in on at least three things the
maintenance of the airplane the pilots
actions as they tried to understand what
was happening and this safety system
that Boeing added to the 737 max that
was supposed to prevent an accident
there we go
it took retired airline captain Ross a
mer just seconds and a 737 simulator to
execute the steps that could have saved
Lion Air flight 610 I have the aircraft
on the control steps those pilots should
have known to do but didn't if they had
immediately followed the procedure
without hesitation turned off the the
cutoff switches this may not have
happened within seconds of taking off
the pilots were locked in a battle for
control of the brand-new 737 max eight
according to the planes flight data
recorder a new anti stall system known
as M casts automatically pushed the
plane's nose down more than two dozen
times during the 11 minute flight before
the pilots lost control
they were clearly on edge they didn't
know what was going on aeronautical
engineer Peter Lemmy studied this newly
released
Datta why the crew would sit there you
know over 20 times and fight it rather
than disabling it as a question you know
we would all like to know investigators
believe a faulty sensor that had failed
on three previous flights triggered em
Cass it was replaced but failed again it
should have been fixed before it left
again it appears the crew on the
previous flight deactivated and cast
after the sensor failed using the same
protocols aimer showed us boeing added m
cache to the max but did not
specifically highlight it in pilot
manuals they decided well this was not
important enough to know and it turns
out it was very important boeing says
the pilots response should have been the
same in a 737 with m casts or without it
so they didn't necessarily need to know
about this anti stall system to prevent
a crash indonesian investigators say
they have not found the cockpit voice
recorders and that could be critical to
understanding what was happening in the
cockpit between the pilots good point
Chris thank you so much